moi je retiens trois quatre mots faire
confiance à nos avec twitter l'un vis
l'investissement l'innovation pour
produire plus et pour produire mieux
hervé comment encourager à l'innovation
d'après 3 merci à toi et marion
probablement reviendra là dessus tout à
leurs innovations et une première chose
dans le pays c'est un enseignement
agricole de grande qualité souvent
pilotes par sa liberté sa capacité
d'innovation
par exemple les lycées agricoles ont des
conseils d'administration présidé par
des personnalités élues et pas par le
proviseur j'ai été présidente conseil
d'administration du lycée agricole à
bourg-lès-valence ça donne une dynamique
ça peut inspirer au passage beaucoup de
pistes pour l'autonomie de
l'enseignement dans d'autres domaines
que l'enseignement agricole
deuxièmement ça vient d'être évoquée par
philippe pinta la science d'où est ce
que je parle je suis député d'une
circonscription très rurale avec en plus
des logiques de production philippe
pinta voit bien cela très
contradictoires très bio c'est le
message et la communication dominant de
ses meilleures années
mais il ya pas si longtemps un champ au
bout de mon jardin était en ogm
nous sommes dans un département
semenciers sur lequel il ya un
affrontement très directe de logique qui
parfois peuvent être réconciliées mais
sur lesquels en tout cas depuis des
années la france a tranché contre la
science est sous le contrôle de philippe
pinta je crois tout de même qu'on peut
dire qui a tout un pan de la recherche
qui considère aujourd'hui que la france
n'est plus un sujet ce n'est pas
véritablement là que ça se passe et
qu'on a pour le moins du terrain à
rattraper ça ne veut pas dire qu'il faut
pas évalué
ça ne veut pas dire que toute initiative
est bonne à prendre mais ça veut dire en
tout cas qui est un renversement d'état
d'esprit qui est absolument considérable
est indispensable quel est notre
attitude collective face aux progrès y
compris est à bien des égards empathique
et dans le domaine agricole les produits
agricoles pour une bonne part d'entre
eux aujourd'hui sont une matière
première est ce qu un pays de haute
valeur ajoutée et à coups de manoeuvre
plutôt élevé à une place dans la
production de matières premières la
réponse est oui c'est souvent au niveau
intermédiaire des filières qu'on se
situe mal aujourd'hui
mais quand on est sur la matière
première on peut avoir une haute
productivité on peut avoir des
mécanisation
on peut avoir l'effet de la science si
on joue cela exemple dans un domaine
totalement différent mais on est en
train de retrouver des parts de marché
non pas dans l'habillement qui est une
activité à haut niveau enfin à forte
intensité de main d'oeuvre
mais dans le textile parce qu'on est sûr
de l'amont qui a besoin d'énergie
quatre jeunes machine cas besoin
d'investissements ce sont des questions
auxquelles on peut répondre en
agriculture
c'est aussi à faire état d'esprit trop
longtemps tous bords politiques
confondus
on a fait la chasse à l'investissement
et aux grands c'est bien gentil de se
payer des séquences aimable contre la
ferme des millevaches
mais à force de tirer sur tout ce qui
est investi et tout ce qui bouge on
finit par interdire tout avenir de
productivité et de production dans notre
pays
je dis rien de très original tu vois
mais je pense qu'il ya la place et on le
dit des gens le disent depuis des années
mais on n'a jamais voulu voir ça il ya
assurément place pour des produits de
spécialité des niches et et déniche dans
le monde d'aujourd'hui qui est un monde
très éclatée avec une très grande
liberté des consommateurs
c'est pas la marge s'est pas marginal ça
peut employer beaucoup de monde et ça
peut faire vivre beaucoup
d'exploitations
il ya une place pour une activité que
jose qualifié de quasi industrielle je
suis désolé d'utiliser le mot mais assez
largement c'est ça je suis pas sûr qu'il
faille véritablement marqué notre
stratégie sur l'antre 2 c'est très
difficile ça peut obliger et justifier
un son de plans sociaux et on est
peut-être dans cette période
aujourd'hui et n'opposons pas sous le
contrôle de marque dans notre pays
pendant tout un tas d'années on a opposé
la mise aux normes des bâtiments
d'élevage et les logiques
d'agrandissement comme si la mise aux
normes des bâtiments d'élevage ne
pouvait se faire qu'à production
constante ou à production restreinte
la logique politique et administrative
imposée en france consistant à dire ça a
été très bien décrit tout à l'heure tu
as très bien dit mettez vous aux normes
et en plus on en rajoute
mais ayez la gentillesse de comprendre
que se mettre aux normes
c'est en même temps réduire sa
production réduire son ambition ça ne
peut pas marcher
alors ok ça demande des moyens ça
demande des moyens en investissement au
milieu de la crise il ya quelques mois
ça a été dit très courageusement par
xavier beulin c'est un langage qu'il est
important de dire qui est porté par la
profession agricole qui n'est pas
toujours porté par le monde politique
parce qu'on est beaucoup dans la
compassion
on est beaucoup dans la thérapie de
groupe et faisons gaffe parce qu'à un
moment on en fait la thérapie et il n'y
aura plus l'agriculture comme activité
productive activités économiques
eric les dictateurs telle qu'elle peut
être et doit être un atout de notre pays
encore un point 2 points sur les normes
juste pour rigoler mais c'est la réalité
je suis actuellement à la commission des
finances rapporteur du budget de
l'écologie et longtemps j'étais
rapporteur budget de la culture
mais christian a eu l'amabilité de me
dire à l'instant c'était il ya très
longtemps mais ce fut passionnant
monsieur le président les habits il faut
que vous sachiez les choses on parle en
france de simplification du droit mais
le mot dans domaine de l'environnement
est interdite
j'ai très vite compris que ceux auxquels
je parlais s'interdisait de parler de
simplification et que le seul mot qu'il
voulait éventuellement utilisé c'était
modernisation du droit de
l'environnement avec en effet une
confusion beaucoup trop fréquentes
ça a été dit par philippe pinta entre
les moyens et les résultats
c'est essentiel la sueur transposition
vous l'avez évoqué tout dernier point
sur la ruralité avec une idée de jeu
mais où débat d'innovation parce que je
pense que nicolas sarkozy reviendra
là-dessus plan marshall pour la ruralité
on a besoin de moyens
regardons l'évolution de notre pays
devient sombre d'année au fil de ces
dernières années
c'est assez largement l'agriculture qui
financent et qui paye budgétairement
financièrement administrativement pour
l'environnement le développement du 2e
pilier de la pac a entraîné des
basculements de financement qui
historiquement aller directement sur des
actions agricoles et ce qui au fil du
temps sont ni davantage sur des dépenses
d'environnement et sa palette s'arranger
ami ben je propose de renverser le
principe plutôt que ce soit
l'agriculture qui payent pour
l'environnement que ce soit
l'environnement qui payent pour
l'agriculture
traduction concrète traduction concrète
taxe carbone ou contribution climat
énergie taxe carbone c'est un impôt
assez sympa parce que si je te demande
comment tu paye la taxe carbone tu sais
pas répondre
en tout cas moi je sais pas toi tu es
meilleur tu sais mais moi je sais pas
donc c'est le genre d'impôt aseptisé on
vous en parle il n'y a pas de raison de
gueuler on sait pas combien c'est enfin
j'ai fait un petit calcul
ce qui est dans les tuyaux décidées par
le gouvernement aujourd'hui c'est une
augmentation moyenne de la fiscalité des
carburants de 20 centimes par litre à
horizon 2020 30 centimes à horizon 2030
si on continue la chasse au gazole dont
les arguments écologiques sont très
fragiles la chasse au gazole je veux
dire vous imaginez que ça peut être plus
sur le gazole et moins sur l'essence se
veut donc dire en milieu rural n'ont pas
20 centimes est plutôt volontiers 30
d'ici 2020 30 centimes par litre d'ici
2020 les amis ça s'en passer on n'est
pas contre la taxe carbone parce qu'il
faut qu'il y ait un signal écolo mais
mais la situation peut vite devenir
insupportable dans ce que je propose et
j'offre cette idée et je m'arrête là
très bien c'est que c'est que je pense
que l'idée est importante et qu'elle
apporte aux débats c'est que la
contribution climat énergie soit pour
une part importante contribué mobilisée
pour financer le plan marshall dont nous
parlons plus précisément qu'il soit bien
vérifier que le monde rural ne participe
pas davantage à la politique de
l'environnement et en particulier à la
taxe carbone qu'il ne reçoive je résume
une idée innovante
une idée simple et gens ne demandent pas
plus que ça dans des bas mais faut
apporter des idées concrètes que la taxe
carbone que la contribution climat
énergie soit mise au service du
financement du développement rural
merci à hervé pour ce témoignage vécu
est vrai